hey what is up guys on Kibby HD here and
I just got back from an event by HTC
across the river in New York City which
is why I have this this is the all-new
HTC One m8 so of course I'm going to go
ahead and give you guys my very first
impressions of it now obviously this is
one of the most leaked phones of all
time so we basically knew everything
that was going to be announced but of
course hundreds of people came to the
event and liveblog the official
announcement anyway and now the device
is out and in the wild and people
actually get to see it so physically
this device is going to look very
similar to the old HTC One it resembles
it a lot especially on the front because
of those boom sound speakers no other
phone really does that yet so you're
going to think it looks very similar to
the old HTC One but there are three main
differences that really distinguish it
from that other phone so first of all
number one it has a larger display it's
a 5-inch 1080p display same awesome
brightness same awesome sharpness but of
course now it has on-screen buttons and
it's bigger and that brings us to number
two which is the device itself is a lot
taller so it brings its height in a lot
higher than the old HTC one if you look
at them side-by-side it makes it really
easy to tell but the phone is not that
much wider and number three is a lot
more rounded off so they rounded the
metal from the back of the phone all the
way around to the sides so there's not
nearly as much polycarbonate and the
overall shape of the phone is a lot more
rounded on the corners so the entire
device looks a bit more sleek a little
bit more graceful less sharp edges and
maybe that feels better in the hand I'll
probably be able to figure that in a
couple of days of using it but it's
definitely a much more round device now
but of course because it's metal it
screams quality and the rest of the
specs are pretty high-end as well
nothing too overly extreme here but with
that Snapdragon 801 quad-core chip the
1080p display and the latest version of
Android 4.4 with HTC Sense 6 on top they
made a witty pun about Sixth Sense but
it's a pretty obvious that this is a
flagship caliber device for HTC inside
and out so around the back here we have
one of the most talked about parts of
the phone as soon as it was announced at
the event people started chatting about
it it's the cameras so on the back here
we have a 4.1 megapixel camera we're
sticking with that
pixelmon occur like I said we would and
what to expect video and then above that
we have a second sensor so HTC calls
this the duo camera system and it's
supposed to allow you to refocus a
picture after you take it so if you have
something fancy in the foreground and
something fancy in the background you
can refocus on exactly what you want
after you took the shot and have a nice
soft blur over the out-of-focus parts
for my limited experience though this
feature doesn't even really work very
well actually looks super artificial in
the finished results but at least this
is something they can improve in
software pretty quickly since it's in
the Play Store and this new duo camera
API is also public so developers can
build the feature into their own apps
and maybe make it a little better than
HTC does so but basically a lot of
people are still bummed about the fact
that this main camera is a four
megapixel camera which is actually means
the the wide-angle front-facing camera
is a higher resolution you know for
those selfies now we'll be doing a lot
of testing with these cameras in the
next couple of days and weeks before my
full review video so definitely stay
tuned for that but right now what I can
say is they did make some sacrifices
there's no more optical image
stabilization there's now a two-tone
flash on the back which I have to
experiment with I usually don't use
flash on my cameras anyway but it's
there so there's a lot of things I need
to figure out but what I got to say is
when I was taking pictures with it in
New York City in the viewfinder while I
was taking the pictures they looked
great they looked fantastic it was very
high frame rate it looked like if the
shutter was really really fast to fire
the autofocus was extremely fast that
was excellent but then looking at the
photos afterwards after I took them they
resembled the same as photos from the
old HTC one which is okay it's not
particularly high resolution but
obviously like we said it's much better
in low light than the typical camera
even though it doesn't have oh is any
more so we'll have to play with this a
lot more I think a lot of people are
going to be curious about the
differences between this camera and the
old HTC One camera also HTC Sense has
been redesigned and that isn't really
getting as much media attention because
we're not really focusing on that but
this is easily the cleanest most modern
version of since UI yet it's definitely
definitely still a skin no mistaking
that but the redesign helps it stay
unintrusive and I'm liking this design a
bit more than a last one of course it
still has you know the
speakers on any phone by a long long way
I still have battery life to test I
still have some sweet new accessories to
test and even a Google Play edition is
on the way but at the moment it's clear
to me that the main focus of this phone
is designed HTC knows that the one was
one of the best designed phones of 2013
that's what wanted all the awards and I
guess they figured the best way to
capitalize on that is to continue to
focus on design and creating a phone
that feels good looks good and works
well but other than that that's
basically it these are my first
impressions of the all-new HTC One m8
definitely leave a comment below of
things you want to see me cover in the
full review when that goes live and
leave a thumbs up below if you enjoyed
this video and also there's a subscribe
button below so you'll be one of the
first to see and not miss the upcoming
videos on the mkbhd channel so you'll be
first to see the review so either way
that's been it thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you guys in the next video
peace